I was a at a family holiday event and I
was talking about how China was
potentially getting access to the DNA
from covid tests and you know one
individual was like what get out of here
that's BS that's not true you can't say
that and then I just pulled up my phone
pulled up NPR reporting it I handed to
him they read and they went oh wow I
didn't know that and I'm like you're
sitting here thinking I'm wrong about
this I was just citing NPR of all
sources what happens when they go no and
they pull up a video and they show you
the video and you go that's not a real
video they'll say you're a conspiracy
theorist and you're lying I have the
video
so what's the best way to authenticate
those though impossible defects yeah we
were talking about that today in one of
our development meetings I don't know I
think it's going to have to be either
the person verifies the video themselves
and if it's a video of you that you
don't verify then there's no
verification I think it's going to be a
lot easier to verify the real ones
rather than sniffing out all the fake
ones but then people like project
Veritas will try and catch someone
they'll be like no I don't that wasn't a
real video